let's talk about critical race there in
these schools kenny where where are you
from
uh i'm from uh virginia were you born in
virginia i was born in maryland i moved
to virginia
when i was three years old born in
maryland
so you're an american and you just
happen to be of uh
asian descent you you uh of asian
ethnicity your parents are asian but you
are an american citizen
right what i see in this in what the
schools are doing like harvard to
to asian americans to people of asian
descent is they're simply saying
because you look like those people you
can't go to the school
that's it yeah they're treating you
based on something that you can't
control about yourself they're also
treating you based on something you
didn't consent to give them
you know uh harvard asked for ask for
race uh in
your college application but even if you
don't give your race
don't they're still gonna find out what
race you are because they have an access
to
a database of all the students in the
entire country and they know not just
your race
they know your uh they know your
family's household income
they know you're the neighborhood that
you live in they know the school that
you went to they know the crime rate of
the school that they went to
and so regardless of how you consent to
this if you consent to give this
information
or not they're going to treat you based
on it you know and this is the new
this is the marriage harvard's
admissions process
is the marriage of racial profiling with
data mining
that's what it is it is it represents an
authoritarian future
but yeah no no it represents an
authoritarian future
where people um are going to
get information from you without your
consent and
things like race background everything
like that and then judge you on it
that that is what the authoritarians
will eventually do and harvard's process
is an example of
where we're going as a culture the main
thing i see here that is that is
the most alarming is as we've mentioned
earlier in the show the left doesn't
view
individuals they don't see individuals
their whole system is comprised of
utility that's it
that's why they're like how many asians
are in the school too many how many
white people too many how many latinos
not enough how many black people not
enough
they don't care about the individuals
and the work being done and they don't
care about the fact that
there could quite literally be a black
man who was born in spain
and he's hispanic he speaks spanish and
so they're like ah but his skin looks a
certain way
and then you have american americans in
this country
who are of any background and they're
like
we want you to go to the school simply
because of
how you look what the how what does that
matter
it doesn't matter at all i can't believe
there were a point where they're simply
saying
we want people to look different it's
interesting
it's it's an interesting conversation
because genetically
obviously we're different everyone's
different and probably because of our
ancestry
there's subtle differences in our
genetics that are interesting to talk
about
um i i just
oh god i had another part of that point
that i that i did well the the point is
regardless of certain things like i went
to uh
thailand and i was taller than everybody
right
i certainly think through hard work and
dedication and commitment
and uh you can achieve great things and
become the best of the best the best
now of course there's there's always
going to be a michael phelps he's got
a wider arm span than normal and if
someone was saying like
his he produces less lactate uh what is
it a lactic acid or something yeah
so this makes him just the best swimmer
ever yeah well you know that happens and
that's kind of why we have competition
but most people can earn experience and
skills
and work hard and be dedicated and make
themselves better in a variety of ways
maybe you're not the smartest you could
be the strongest maybe you're not the
tallest you can be
you can be super fast you can work
really hard mugsy bows man that guy
could 360 dunk that dude
could jump so high it doesn't matter in
my opinion what you look like
it matters if you have this the
determination the the the commitment
the willingness to do better to be
better and so what the problem i have
with all of this is first and foremost
how insane is it that these people would
look
at a a 10 year old vietnamese kid whose
parents came here from from vietnam and
they say
oh honey you can't go to harvard you
look like those people too much
that's it for the only reason you will
never go to this ivy league school
you look like those that that's insane
to me yes people are scumbags
well you know i agree with you there
look um and i'll just show you some
facts look
harvard university um you have to score
if you're an asian american you have to
score 440 points higher on the s.a.t to
have the same chance of admission
as a black american wow yeah simply
because you both have different color
skins
simply because you bought the different
colors out of 1600 points if you
submitted
the out of 1600 if you no actually that
was out of 2 400.
back in the old 2400 days if you
submitted
an application the exact same
application
and you have the same sat score the same
grades the same objective metrics you
the only thing you did was you changed
your race from asian to black
a harvard admissions officer is going to
look at the asian application and
they're going to say
oh he's just like all the other asians
she's probably groomed by his parents
overachieving
test-taking nerd no personality you
change it to black the story is most
likely going to be
oh my gosh this guy is the greatest
thing since sliced bread we have to
admit him and give him everything
yeah when i was like yeah and it's not
and the thing is
the thing is they they say they do this
to
admit the you know kids from
underprivileged backgrounds but if you
look at the
even the black admits at harvard
university
70 70 plus percent of them are upper
middle class or higher and 50
of them are immigrants or children of
black
immigrants so they're not even admitting
the kid from the south side of chicago
you know who who you may think deserves
or should get that chance they're
admitting
the privileged kid who looks black yep
what what a disgusting uh reality i
suppose when i when i was growing up i
was told
never to let anyone know that i was
asian if i was applying for a job
i would have to lie i started putting
other on my things like
10 years ago or 15 years ago it's just
so gross i remember i was applying for a
job
and i was told oh just just don't put
asian put mexican or something else i
was like why
and i was told asians don't have
powerful special interest
groups so they don't get special favors
in government and
people are allowed to discriminate
against you on the basis of your race if
you tell them that you tell them the
truth
about you know your family is it what do
you say lydia doesn't it strike you as
unbelievably racist for them to look at
a black applicant and be like
holy cow this person is insanely special
do you remember what joe biden said
about obama sir
jeez he said
it it's he said what do you say the
first articulator yeah
he's so articulated such an articulate
gentleman yeah and i was like what
like i think they call it race realism
when you talk about the actual
genetic differences of and i don't even
think it's different races
am i right to say that like the human
well race realists believe
in like hard racial differences right
and which i mean according to genetics i
think there are there's a reason why
skin colors come out differently they
take it into a very s like
that's the problem with it because it's
a fascinating conversation just to know
but that doesn't mean that we're
different like that we have different um
senses of freedom we're all equally
valuable and able
yes and i think one of the problems with
race realism is that
people look a lot of people make
assumptions it's how humans work
we look at something we say here's why i
think i think this is why it's happening
let me test that
and then race realists think if i see
you know something like the bell curve
uh and i see these differences based on
a cue it
clearly must be the racial component and
perhaps some of it you know i think it
was sam harris and a few other uh i
think i'm not sure who was sam harris
and maybe some idw people saying
there's some component there obviously
why wouldn't there be but
they think it's the end-all be-all
absolute reason and
i think that is likely incorrect i do
think there's a mix between nature and
nurture for sure
but i think human potential is is
typically not met and that means
regardless of your race if you study
hard and you work hard you can be the
best of the best of the best
you might not be like the number one
position but you might
but you might it's just it's just it's
just there's eight billion people you
know
it's one in eight billion to be number
one who knows who that's going to be or
why
i think part of what kenny is seeing and
part of what you see with these
black kids being like the kids of
nigerian immigrants
is a cultural thing so tim's talking
about how that you look a certain way so
that means you're not going to have a
chance to get in do you think it is how
you look or do you think it's at least
partly because of the asian cultural
preference
for hard work and studying and all that
so you know this is a complicated
question i'm not a race realist
i i think that predominantly what
explains
uh disparities in i think predominantly
what just
what uh predicates disparities in the
united states with regards to a lot of
these things is cultural
i think that cultural factors for
example asian americans
don't come to the u.s with like a
significantly higher iq
than the average person and in fact
studies have shown that asians with
lower iq are able to overcome that lower
iq
because they study pretty hard they work
really hard and they're actually able to
compete with
whites at an iq bracket it's a quintile
higher a quintile
standard deviation higher than them so
this is this is this is this is massive
this is
this shows you that it's not just your
iq
that makes you successful you really
have to put in the work and what asian
americans do
on average and i'm saying this on
average every individual is different
there are a lot of
asian americans who don't work hard but
asian americans individually on
average study twice as many hours as the
average american per week
and it's well i'll tell you this i think
it's cultural it is
like you guys are i i was i was i was
tutored by my mom when i was
like one or two and she's she's korean
what is she
100 korean like born in korea half
korean no born in united states
okay her parents were one of her parents
was from korea yep born in korea
i don't know exactly where but my
grandmother was when i was in korean
and that trickles down a little bit
i suppose i would imagine i mean i value
free speech
because i'm an american because i was
born here and raised here with these
cultural values if i have children i'm
going to pass those on to my children
it's not because of the way
i look but the people that are my
progeny
or look like me then you will but it's
not even about that
you believe in free speech yes and your
parents came from china
there you go the chinese communist party
does not believe in free speech
people can be whatever you know what i
mean that's why
you know uh there there was a story that
came out recently gallup poll
race relations are worse than they've
been in like for a really
long time and i think it's because
millennials are extremely racist
i think that modern leftist and
progressive millennials
are the most racist we've seen in a very
very very long time
and so that's why you see around like
2013 race relations
plummet because this is when millennials
start aging
into the workforce into influential
positions
and they start espousing their racist
ideology
now you have racist millennials admitted
white supremacists like robin deangelo
espousing racist ideals
and then all of a sudden you've got a
bunch of minorities being like yo these
people are racist
what when alma really did lay on that
race card
during occupy wall street when the
occupy activists
segregated all the activists by race i
remember
seeing yeah no joke they did crazy they
created race-based caucuses for voting
on how the how the the body would spend
money let me talk to the media it was
crazy
they literally they literally but they
literally had like the hispanic caucus
the asian caucus the people of color
caucus the black caucus
and so i remember they split up all the
groups based on race and there was this
black dude chilling because the
zucchini park where occupy happens is
slightly downhill so there's like this
ledge that slowly turns into a very
highlight it's like very small
at the top of the by the street and then
as you walk down the ground goes down
the ledge stays the same height and he's
sitting up on top of it i see him
arguing with somebody
and i walk over and i'm listening to him
and he just goes do you have any idea
what the press is gonna say when they
find out y'all segregated based on
race and i started laughing and i'm like
dude yes like
these people have lost it but you know
what their ideology is winning
that's crazy because it's so it has
the the the question of success in
america has
much less to do with your race
your race than it has to do with these
cultural values that can be adopted
by any race and to say uh i mean
you know hard work studying hard any
race can do it doesn't matter if you're
asian they call that
you can study hard if you're white that
was that that was did you know that yeah
do you see that thing you're black did
you see that that graphic they had on
the
was the african-american history museum
whatever yeah and it said like working
hard and having a schedule was whiteness
that to me is absolutely insane but i
will add
yeah there have been several studies
done and they found
one trait that guarantees success or i
should say
one trait that was was highly correlated
with success
iq right no no is it wealth is that a
trait
it yes it isn't wealth it is an iq it
isn't race
it isn't uh national origin it isn't
gender
it's perseverance great that's for sure
one thing they found
among every group every race every
gender every age bracket every iq
bracket
every class was those who refused to
give up succeeded and those who gave up
failed
yep that's incredible i mean yeah this
is one example this is one reason why
black americans who
join the military who join the army
actually tend to have much
higher career success outcomes both
military and
non-military afterwards um you know in
the army you're taught things like
perseverance you're taught things like
overcoming and resilience and everything
like that and the people who are put
with that kind of structure in their
lives you know
can can really elevate and that's why
you see black americans who
are in the military you know are
disproportionately well represented
among the upper middle and
and upper classes in america when you
were um
studying the uh the meritocracy and the
failure of is it harvard
is it harvard that's doing these
emissions things was that we said it's
okay so
here's the thing about this this crazy
thing that's happening at harvard
all of this this admissions process this
race
baiting and and profiling started at
harvard but it
has since it has since grown to become
an entire ivy league phenomenon and then
from there
the ivy league exported this ideology to
big corporations like google and
facebook and now you see google and
facebook and their diversity and
inclusion programs
also be anti-asian you know i just
published this article in collette
magazine
asians make up 90 of silicon valley's
software engineers
wow 90 of silicon valley software
engineers but you go up
each level of management
asians get lower and lower and lower
percentage until in the executive level
they're only like 20
of the executive level of facebook and
google and
um you know this this is an example of
and and nobody is advocating for asians
to be hired more
or promoted more in silicon valley and
things like that because they don't fit
the narrative because they're still
considered over represented
meritocracy man yeah have you found the
if you earn it if you can do it
then there you go look if you were you
able to isolate methodologies that
enhance meritocracy amongst
education and business so i think that
one of the things that you have to
so first of all um you know i understand
iq is is correlated significantly with
with performance in college and
particularly
not just iq but standardized test scores
you have to look at objective metrics
like standardized test scores that
people love to rip on tests they love to
rip on standardized tests i get it it's
a lot of work you have to study
but the standardized test measures two
things that are meritorious
it measures your innate intelligence and
it measures
how hard you prepare right because you
have to prepare for tests and if you
don't study for tests you're lazy
if you're lazy you're not going to do
well in school right so now harvard is
trying to get rid of standardized tests
of admissions
um why they say you know it
disproportionately
benefits the wealthy and privileged over
you know poor black and latino students
you know they point to the fact that
blacks tend to do
worse on standardized tests than than
other people but what they conveniently
leave
out is that standardized tests actually
correct
for wealth and privilege because if
you're a
poor kid and an immigrant kid who has no
social connections
you're not you're not going to be able
to stand out
except to you're not going to be able to
stand out when compared next to a rich
and wealthy kid except through the
standardized tests right
right you know this is the standardized
test is the only test that allows you to
be able to compete
side by side with a wealthy and
privileged kid and beat them
because typically what happens is the
guy shows up talks to the dean and says
my son would like to go here let me give
a donation to the west wing and
soccer team you're funded lacrosse team
you're funded it gets in
and nearly 10 of harvard's
new class could be considered a children
of a donor a child of a donor
that make this dean's list that harvard
uses to signify
primarily children of donors and 35
of them are legacies what's that what's
a legacy a legacy is a is a kid whose
parents
went to harvard yep yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you